you are the defending world champions
you know you're going to get
every team's best shot but in las vegas
the raiders all-time leader in passing
touchdowns won't catch anyone off guard
eight sports now reporter molly sullivan
has our week five preview
you may recall raiders quarterback
derrick carr telling us during training
camp that when he breaks the huddle
it just feels different now the pieces
are in place thanks to general manager
mike mayok and now in week five
those pieces are starting to make their
way back from injury as las vegas has
yet to play at full strength both
offensively
and defensively and if you're a raiders
fan that is perhaps what's going to make
you most fired up because
the raiders are standing tall at two and
two as they prepare to
hit the road to take on the defending
super bowl champion kansas city chiefs
one of six teams in the nfl that remain
undefeated this season
kansas city has won four straight afc
west division titles and have also
started the season 4-0 for the fourth
straight year
a first in nfl history which leads us to
a good old-fashioned
afc west showdown but number four said
don't call it a rivalry until they pull
off the upset
carr is looking to lead his team to
victory at arrowhead stadium for the
first time in his career
head coach jon gruden quick to point out
how his quarterback is the biggest
reason why the raiders have a chance at
heading into bye week with arguably
the biggest regular season w there is on
paper
gruden went on to detail how turnovers
and lack of takeaways have been the
deciding factors in their previous four
match-ups
chiefs quarterback patrick mahomes has
not committed a turnover this season
and is on pace for his highest
quarterback rating and completion
percentage of his career
the former league mvp and super bowl mvp
is also coming off a monday night win
over the new england patriots
where he said that he didn't execute at
a high enough level
proving that a loaded stat line doesn't
always translate
when you break down the film a common
trend you'll see in teams that
legitimately go toe-to-toe with the
chiefs is that
they don't beat themselves las vegas is
focusing on the things they can control
eliminating those self-inflicted
mistakes continues to be the point of
emphasis here at intermountain
healthcare performance center
in henderson molly sullivan 8 sports